bonsoir et bienvenue de 7,8 l'actu en ce
mercredi soir nous débutons tout d'abord
avec cette mobilisation du taxi c'était
en fin de matinée du côté de saint cyr
l'école avoir vous le savez depuis
quelques jours le conflit qui oppose les
chauffeurs de taxi aux véhicules de
tourisme avec chauffeur les vtc provoque
une forte mobilisation et ce malgré la
nomination d'un médiateur
thomas thévenoud qui dirigera une
mission de concertation alors pour faire
simple les taxis et les vtc ont le même
client mais pas les mêmes règles
par exemple contrairement aux taxis et
les vtc ne peuvent pas prendre de
clients à la volée et depuis mercredi
dernier le décret instaurant le délai de
15 minutes a été supprimée par le
conseil d'état alors sur le département
sachez que les autorisations de
stationnement autrement dit les fameuses
licences se négocie à partir de cent
mille euros pour les taxis alors que
l'enregistrement d'un véhicule de
tourisme ne coûte que 100 euros pour ces
chauffeurs évinois peu l'on a vu sur ces
images assez remonté les vtc c'est tout
simplement la mort annoncée des taxis on
travaille déjà à la réservation
fonctions plus vous fait rentrer ce
genre de transport
vous allez créer tout de suite une
concurrence déloyale vis-à-vis de soi
c'est déjà que l'achat des autorisations
de stationnement
et puis de l'autre côté au niveau de la
clientèle elle ne sait plus faire la
différence entre un chauffeur vtc
voilà pourquoi le chauffeur de taxi
aujourd'hui nous demandons à ce que
l'état une bonne fois pour toutes
légifère ce travail à la demande et les
taxis il vous noie prévoient de
manifester ce vendredi sur paris une
page culture pour continuer c'est ce
mercredi que débute l'exposition street
art au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines une exposition dans
le cadre de la 3ème saison pulsations
urbaine consacré cette année aux 30 ans
du hip hop sur le territoire alors
baptisé stricte culture saint-quentin
s'intéresse naturellement au hip hop
mais plus largement aux autres cultures
comme le skate la danse ou le graphe
jusqu'au 28 juin à travers l'exposition
le musée donne la parole aux street
artistes du territoire qui ont accepté
de témoigner de leur univers de création
philosophie de rue comme nous
l'expliquent lucie sauvage où elle est
chargée de l'action culturelle au musée
de la ville
cette culture là est une culture
importante sur le territoire pas
seulement à saint quentin en yvelines
mais c'est une culture qui est souvent
pas assez reconnus et elle mérite qu'on
en parle c'est une culture qui est aussi
connu pour ses aspects des fois qu'ils
peuvent dégrader ou voilà qui peuvent
être nuisibles des nuisances sonores
pour ce qui est des skateurs une licence
pour les graffeurs qui tague parfois
mais c'est aussi une culture qui a des
valeurs vraiment propres qui sont
importantes et revendiquée à la fois de
se débrouiller soi même mais aussi du
respect de l'autre de la valeur par la
compétence et pas par parce qu'on aime
ou par la valeur sociale
c'est des choses qui sont très
importantes pour les hip hopeurs c'est
qu'on a voulu traduire dans cette
exposition
allez on continue on va parler culture
et loisirs avec vous fabrique le waf
second soir c'est le directeur
d'exploitation de france miniature à
elancourt ya pas de street art france
miniature à il n'est pas conseillé que
les artistes viennent graf et le lien
quelques tags ont tags des quelques
wagons des trains qui circulent sur le
pacs et cédant 1 istres artistique alors
on essaie de se rapprocher du paysage
francilien est qui qui compte quelques
tags sur ces wagons d'accord le parc de
france miniature existe depuis 22 ans à
la sortie de l'hiver vous fermé pendant
quelques mois et puis vous rouvrez vous
allait rouvrir notamment ce samedi alors
pourquoi d'avant le parc fermé
le parent ferme parce que les conditions
météo hivernales sont assez peu
favorable à une visite extérieure comme
celle du parc
et puis c'est également un moment
propice à faire quelques quelques
contrats baux à la france miniature 717
ma tête
117 ce qu'a essayé huit attractions
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu est-ce qu
on peut voir en gros c'est la france en
petit c'est un petit résumé de la france
l'a résumé de la france sur une
demi-journée alors d'émoluments très
connu la tour eiffel fort boyard
et puis des monuments qui ont une
notoriété plus régionale mais qui ont
une particularité architecturale qui
font qu il représente également la
france
laurent dehors évidemment des châteaux
de versailles sur le département il ya
des monuments guînois oui le château de
brut
le château de saint germain en laye et
le château de versailles saint quentin
me l'étais pas là au départ à
l'ouverture du parc du château de
versailles n'est pas là mais il ya une
telle demande y compris de la clientèle
de 2010 au premier monument à
l'ouverture alors y avait plus de
montlivault à l'ouverture du parc le
parc où il ya 22 ans avec à peu près 150
maquette mais sans attraction
et puis il ya une volonté de ramener un
petit peu d'amusement et de réduire le
nombre de maquettes au profit de
quelques attractions sa valeur des
monuments qui ont disparu d'accord
effectivement vous l'avez parlé il ya
des animations n'y a pas que que des
maquettes c'est aussi des animations
quelles sont ces nouvelles animations
qui vont être à découvrir à partir de
samedi des animations ponctuelles en
lien un petit peu avec l'actualité du
parc pour les vacances de février nous
proposons un en partenariat avec le
magasin picwic de maurepas un concours
de masques vous aurez la possibilité du
matériel pour faire des masques sur
place ou repartir avec
et puis une mise à disposition de jeux
de société pour faire une petite pause à
l'intérieur
si le temps n'était pas clément pour
passer un petit peu en famille ou voir
affronter d'autres visiteurs donc ça
c'est du mercredi au dimanche à naples
on dire ça c'est tous les jours des
vacances de février puis une autre
animation sur deux dimanches du mois de
mars en partenariat avec eads un
ambassadeur de eads qui viendra vous
raconter l'espace les satellites les
fusées juste à côté de la maquette de la
fusée ariane
donc là pendant les vacances de février
carnaval et après on s'envole dans
l'espace
voilà qui valait je sais que ça sera les
dimanches 9 et 16 mars ekland avril
aussi des animations fêtes et des
animations tous les mois comme ça tous
les mois ou avril on parlera chocolat on
fera des petits ballotins enfants
fabriquons des petits ballotins pour
repartir avec
en mai on est en train de préparer des
animations autour de la magie le mois de
juin
autour de la musique au mois de juillet
lopy et la découverte et la recherche
d'insectes au milieu des maquettes
lorsqu'on sait peut-être pas c'est que
le parc soit transmis nature fait partie
du même groupe qu'un autre musique et
une prestigieux qui est le musée grévin
ou encore la mer de sable on se dit pour
faire vivre un parc comme le vôtre il
faut effectivement proposer des
maquettes mais on est obligé de proposer
des animations on est obligé de
s'adapter à aujourd'hui où il venait
marie g de faire évoluer le produit pour
proposer 2 de l'amusement la visite des
maquettes elle est un petit peu passive
c'est un des parfois un reproche que
nous font nos clients et on est obligé
douala doha cette année m'a bien des
choses à l'envers voilà on aimerait bien
touché mais c'est délicat de toucher les
pièces elles sont plutôt fragile voilà
donc on a interdit de toucher mais ça
génère une certaine frustration
on sait bien quand on a le dos tourné on
retrouve quelques visiteurs et ça fait
des photos
c'est assez amusant et c'est plutôt
sympa de se retrouver au milieu du
château de versailles comme un gérant
château de versailles
beaucoup de gens qu'on retrouve à côté
de l'arc de triomphe
c'est celui qui a le plus de succès la
patron en photos interdites oui c'est
vrai vous avez tout c'est probablement
un don dans l'axé le plus facile
d'accord combien de visiteurs chaque
année à peu près 180 190 milles et puis
une année 2013 un petit peu plus plus
difficile mais je vais on espère dès
2014 retrouver cette vitesse de
croisière un petit peu à peu près 160
mille visiteurs famille visiteurs de moi
à votre avis c'est quoi c'est l'effet
crise où c'est le temps parce qu'il n'a
pas fait beau selon prononcer demain
jusqu'au printemps et puis certainement
un effet de crise des études nous
montrent qu'un français sur deux fait
quelques sacrifices au niveau de ses
loisirs les vacances ou pendant les
petites sorties
c'est quelque chose que nous avons bien
ressenti sur le prix d'entrée du parc
est froid et à 20 euros pour les adultes
savent à 14 euros pour les enfants c'est
pas donner ça sont les prix sur place
vous retrouvez notamment par le biais de
notre site internet des billets tarif
enfant pour tout le monde
la condition de réserver au moins quatre
jours à l'avancé et puis on dit marche
de nombreux comités d'entreprises
d'associations de personnel où on
propose des billets à des prix
légèrement
quelque peu affaibli que vous accueillir
l'impression que c'est plutôt de famille
s'est très légèrement des des familles
sont la clientèle la plus nombreux sur
france miniature me retrouve aussi
beaucoup d'adultes seul qui viennent
plus chercher le patrimoine
l'aspect culturel du parc et puis à peu
près 20% de la clientèle sont des
groupes d'enfants qui viennent dans le
cadre de sorties scolaires ou avec le
centre de loisirs
cette année au niveau des monuments n'y
a pas de nouveauté n'y a pas de
nouveauté dans ce qu'on vient terminer
carcassonne qui était la grande
nouveauté dans ça reste une maquette
c'était un chantier un peu compliqué
pour nous et il va et vient des vient
d'être terminé justement comment se sont
confectionnés où sont confectionnés ses
maquettes
elles étaient confectionnés auparavant
sur le site de france miniature même clé
maintenant il ya eu un petit peu de
construction sur place mais l'essentiel
de deux des constructions de maquettes
sam etiassé assez particulier se fait
par le biais de sous traitants et qui
eux mêmes deviennent de plus en plus
rares ça devient dirigeants qui savent
des gens qui savent faire de la maquette
on est encore attaché à des gens qui
travaillent de façon artisanale
on commence à trouver des fabricants de
maquettes qui utilisent beaucoup le
numérique
alors on continue nous a travaillé avec
plus des petits artisans qui apporte une
maquette avec rihanna 3d donc c'est
peut-être la révolution de la demande de
la maquette salle imprimantes 3 de
l'après-vente 3d aujourd'hui elle se
limite à des petites pièces mais il ya
aussi fin des grandes imprimantes enfin
des des grandes machines pour faire des
grandes surfaces mais c'est des choses
très précises très régulière qui ne sont
pas forcément le reflet de monuments
fabriqués ou construits au moyen-âge n'a
pas la perfection attaque on rendrait
avec nous dans ce cas elles sont
préparées sur place elles sont réparés
elles sont entretenus sur place 117
maquette vous le disiez on a une
rotation de rénovation à peu près 30
maquette par an du coup chaque mac a été
rénové tous les 4-5 ans au maximum
d'accord merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de 7,8 l actu et je rappelle que
le parc de france miniature pour ceux
qui aiment les
les maquettes ouvre à partir de ce
samedi et puis votre parc n'est pas le
seul à rouvrir et ce week-end pour
croire que c'est ni fait valider cette
période et réouverture le parc animalier
de thoiry qui est fermé depuis le 12
novembre ouvre également ses portes ce
samedi à partir de 10h c'est l'occasion
évidemment de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir les animaux de la réserve
ainsi que l'arche des petites bêtes qui
était la dernière nouveauté qui présente
des amphibiens et des vertébrés voilà
parc de thoiry ça c'est les animaux en
liberté
et puis puisqu'on fait le tour des parcs
et bien on continue avec la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet qui va proposer
des animations pendant ces vacances
scolaires du 15 février au 2 mars tous
les après midi de 14h à 17h30 alors des
animations autour du thème du cirque
les visiteurs pour bien entendu
découvrir les animaux mais également
s'initier à la jonglerie et à la courbe
l'acrobatie se dédisent est encore en
clowns ou encore assister à un spectacle
animalier donc c'est à la bergerie
nationale on va quitter le monde animal
pour celui des humains durant trois
jours à cinéaste et amateurs se sont
donné rendez-vous à jouy en josas pour
la cinquième édition du festival
international de courts métrages
elsa zylberstein originaire de la
commune et marraine de l'événement s'est
prêté au jeu des échanges avec le public
des moments privilégiés très apprécié
par les spectateurs
le temps d'un week end le théâtre du
vieux marché à jouy en josas s'est
transformée en salle obscure pour
accueillir le festival international
court métrage festival qui depuis cinq
ans présente des films courts nommé aux
césar et aux oscars au programme cette
année 38 films en compétition un jury de
professionnels et différentes animations
pour le public
en marge des projections ciné concert
ciné des bassines et compte notamment
ainsi que l'ain et rendez vous phare la
rencontre de cinéma avec des
professionnels donner la possibilité au
public vraiment de de pouvoir
pouvoir poser les questions qu'ils ne
doivent pas forcément poser des choses
qui voudraient savoir et
voilà donc on a des invités comme
einstein julie de bona et snj moyens
donc ce sont les trois invités
d'aujourd'hui qui qui ont accepté l
invitation qui ont accepté le jeu entre
guillemets de pouvoir échanger avec le
public surpris de la réaction des gens
même des faits vive le cinéma
les gens aiment toujours vous rencontrez
savoir ce que vous faites sur l'émouvant
rencontrer les gens et c'est spécial
c'est symbolique pour moi georges visât
j'ai commencé à 12,13 à faire de la
danse je faisais des galas de danse au
mois de juin dans cette salle des fêtes
un jour ajoute à ce s'est passé toute ma
vie ici est georges other donc c'était
important et touchants et symbolique
pour moi de revenir ici aujourd'hui je
sais que tout était magique magnifique
j'étais très heureuse de voir comme on
dit des acteurs en grec
et puis j'ai étonné de leur simplicité
et puis de la qualité des échanges de
chaleur qui s'est dégagé plus de
l'évolution du débat aussi parce qu'au
début c'est vrai et j'en étais un peu
plus réservé et au bout d'un moment tout
le monde tout le monde est entré dans le
vif du sujet dans le jeu entre
guillemets et puis et puis il ya eu des
échanges très agréable franchement j'ai
trouvé ça très bien à quelques semaines
de la cérémonie des césar le festival
l'ombre d'un court à tout d'un grand
la proximité des membres du jury et
échanges avec le public complice allez
on reste dans le monde du cinéma samedi
c'est le signer cette d'elancourt
organisé la projection du film se battre
réalisé par jean pierre duret et andrea
santana le long métrage rend hommage à
travers les témoignages de personnes
aidées au travail des bénévoles du
secours populaire français
un secours populaire qui doit faire face
chaque jour à une précarité grandissante
dans les yvelines près de 1800 bénévoles
viennent en aide aux plus démunis comme
nous l'expliquent michel brion il est
bénévole depuis deux ans à elancourt ils
étaient présents la projection du film
nous on se bat nous mêmes et les
les bénéficiaires qui viennent nous voir
se bat également pour survivre donc
c'est un mot qui résume exactement qui
peut résumer en un mot ce que nous
sommes
est ce que nous faisons je pense que la
précarité malheureusement loin de
s'éloigner et de plus en plus important
donc je pense qu'il y aura de plus en
plus de gens qu'il va falloir aider tout
en essayant de le regarder le re ligne
était ce qui n'est pas toujours facile
ce 7,8 l'actu terminé merci de votre
attention demain jeudi vous retrouverez
olivier maniscalco il sera question avec
nos invités de sport et de solidarité
bonne soirée